Let us consider what happens when a third example comes along.
And the green outline of this example shows that this is the positive example of
the concept. Because this is the positive example of the concept, we must try to
generalize the most specific model. So a generalization of the specific concept,
that includes this positive example as shown here. Here the meal was breakfast,
here the meal was lunch. So we can generalize over any meal.
Here the day was Saturday, here it was Friday, so we can generalize over
any day. Of course we could have also generalized just Friday or
Saturday, but for simplicity we'll generalize over any day. Similarly for
breakfast or lunch, generalized to any meal. But at this stage, there is
another element to the processing. We must examine all the specializations of
the most general concept and see whether any one of them needs to be pruned out.
The pruning may need to be done in order to make sure that each
specialization here is consistent with the positive examples that are coming in.
So in this case, if we look at the first specialization here,
which says, I'm allergic to breakfast at any place on any day.
This cannot be a generalization of this particular concept. Put another way,
there is no way that this breakfast here can include, can cover,
this positive example which deals with lunch. But yet another way,
the only way I can move from breakfast to any here would be if I generalize, but
in this direction I can only specialize. Therefore, this must be pruned out.
As you prune this first concept out, we're left with only two.